Rachel do you remember the first song
you ever heard for a song no you don't
remember okay
how was a music introduced to your life
when I was I remember but when I was
sharing when I was when I had right now
but you have prematurity was becoming
blind and music was like this the thing
that my parents played that was the
first language that was easy for me
do you remember one of the first songs
that you heard where you just kind of
just felt it was speaking to you
you just really felt alive when I sent
out I by Beethoven because fair release
was another one remember how old you
were
nope okay like - oh wow mm-hmm Wow okay
and then my mom and dad's own
compositions yeah mom jennifer has an
absolute beautiful voice as well no
that's in the film so Lorenzo I
understand that you met Rachel as a
local jazz club which is squash grapes I
love the name by the way and it's in
Ventura it is you want to talk about
that night because I think you went in
not intending to do a film
yeah well mutual friend of ours hands
opps and the guitarist in Ventura
Richard was in his group at the time and
he's a friend and he said she come down
and check out this group and Kelleen
nice young woman is she was 20 at the
time and so I went down with a friend of
mine and Wow you know it's kind of a
revelation the group was tight and and
Rachel was just astonishing and let
genie find out later well I had made a
couple of music films and and lost
sufficient money on those I wasn't
looking to do another
you know but but something clicked you
know because they were right there
locally it was close by so they checked
me out and I checked them out and a
couple months later we were filming and
then we filmed for 53 days over almost a
two-year period so we ended up growing
it grew you know from a small thing into
sort of a big story even though it's a
modest and family and you know it took
on a dimension that we didn't really
know who's going to go that way
what was that conversation like who
approached whom to say I'd like to make
this documentary and how do you feel
about me being a part of your life
basically almost forever because the
film lives on and even if the two of you
never see each other again
you still are around in the events and
you're sure they felt opposed forever
well I think you know they looked at
some I gave a couple of films of mine
musical related yeah Cuban music to a
Minotaur player yeah like jazz guitar
claret you'd heard of him before or that
was a big first time you heard of him
first time as I am yeah so my first
percent and faithful yeah so they I
think there was an element of trust like
this guy kind of knows what he's doing
you mean uh-huh and their terms of my
you know I went to the house for the
first time and Gianna let me clean up
first I'm not sure in some recent
compositions I've been writing on my
computer keyboard at the Simon yeah it
was the beginning of what's been just I
can't count how many times we've hung
out there you know came close
documentaries can be that way usually a
feature some people don't speak to each
other estimate thing is over you know
but I've been lucky that way all the
times I've done it it's become a
long-term relationship so I see no
reason this won't be the same it's not
even longer you know but it those
beginning some filmmakers had approached
you right yeah I didn't follow up and
I was busy with high school and a lot of
other things and I hadn't really
explored things yet yeah
it's kind of a natural you know story it
didn't take a whole lot of brainpower to
see there was a story here I think
probably one of the best decisions I
made was just let's do this you know and
I contacted some crew camera people that
I know and it wasn't a hard sell it's
been easy all along the way in terms of
once they check out some Rachel's work
and they're in you know yeah so she's
the main reason people got on board this
in terms of funding and all the other
thing and unlike any other experience
I've had the kind of support maybe
that's why it just felt right it just
was easy you know when things seem
difficult it's almost like maybe that's
a sign to not get him so it sounds like
that was a sign if other filmmakers had
approached and it kind of fell off so
but where were you in your life at the
time Lorenzo weren't you working and you
had to maybe scale back some of your
work because you know this is a huge
commitment yeah I didn't feel like it
was going to be but you know I was you
know writer-director developing material
and playwright and you know working
those realms I was a film editor for
many years so I came out of film editing
and which was helpful in terms of it's
been helpful in terms of writing into
the story and economy and approach and
things like that but documentary you
just go out and and just suck up
material you know and the photographs
would properly record the sound right
make your choices you know since I
produced and directed it the producer
part was actually more important than
the directing because in a documentary
you're not telling people's stuff to do
maybe say walk over here it was very
minimal directing the producing is
choosing what sequences to show what not
to shoot and the director comes in and
if it's the same person
you just try not to screw it up you know
you shoot it properly recorded properly
and being an editor I kind of know what
I need you know to get in order to be
able to put it together
but yeah it just flowed you know 53 days
is a long time over that period of time
and we staged certain sequences that
were maybe wouldn't have happened you
know and then most of it that was just
what are you doing today
can we tag along so it was kind of a mix
of those two techniques Aikens right and
how was it for you to hear Rachel your
brother Vaughn talking in the film I
mean he was you know he had a fun way
about him but he just said you know he's
an artist - yeah and I found that
interesting that that you were willing
to have him sort of say that I'm sure a
lot of people feel that in families and
yeah forgive me if it's too personal but
I was just wondering if how that was for
you yeah to hear not I remember a while
ago when I was becoming known playing at
a lot of recitals and musical
competitions and recitals and mom would
always take Vaughn to go to them and
Vaughn would he would always hear me
being like the you know recognized a lot
and Vaughn was starting to get a little
uncomfortable with that um yeah so I
when you started getting into drawing I
was like that's pretty cool mm-hmm so
yeah I felt that too so well you come
from a very creative family and you can
see that in many respects is always
something creative going on I'm
wondering how you'll feel about now the
film will be out coming up in just a few
weeks or maybe even less than that
and now the reach will be even broader
people will know even more about your
story your music your family how does
that feel is that exciting very a little
scary pretty exciting we make it be
fascinating for a lot of people to see
like how I got started with playing
music and the family side of it
it's pretty cool that mom and dad were
part of it too because they helped me a
lot when I was very little too so and
when Lorenzo played the film for you who
were you involved in different did you
know it from the beginning were you
hearing sort of a playback of some of
the scenes or was it fresh did you keep
it sort of from Rachel until it was
ready to be out there in the woman she
saw a lot of that's not it
she goes to all the screenings I don't
think she's gotten bored with it hello
ha ha and how was it to hear yourself
and your life it almost feel like it was
another person or did you kind of say
this is me I get it
but at the time when I hear myself talk
it's like yeah that was me so that's
it's funny hearing my own voice when I
play it when it plays back mm-hmm it's
you know she's so got such an ear you
know then we had to edit a lot of the
songs just for length you know sweating
bullets in there hey he's gonna hear
every cut and so when she so that was
pretty good then you know you're okay
uh-huh it was you know obviously I made
the time I wanted to make and they were
so cooperative you don't all the way
down the line I don't know if I'll ever
get that kind of you know reaching
because that shows on sound that they're
willing participants here in the thing
but yeah it's a revelation for everybody
on the crew you know to be it's right
down the street you know if there's a
message cool down a little on the film
it's it's pay attention to the world
around you because they're fascinating
people including yourself in other words
people are you know sort of pushed into
different roles in life yeah I hear this
hear that respect and Rachel's defied
all the odds pretty much
and music being her vehicle you know
yeah we learned a lot fattening it's
nice to learn yep
I love how you show the Dweezil Zappa
balance in Vegas that's awesome that is
my favorite moment that's really cool
first time we played on stage together
do so oh wow okay I had these dreams
before that I remember this dream that I
was playing with Dweezil and his band
and that guitar that I played something
weird happened to the guitar and then
one of one of my friends helped that six
tickets are and got it set back up
and then later on my something we would
happen it was my guitar like in the
dream when we figured that out and then
is playing with stuido we played a
different song but it was is pretty cool
mm-hmm he'd heard of her I did a lot of
her yeah I did a lot of Frank Zappa
tunes on Soundcloud oh wow
and the weasel heard them and he was
impressed and they talked about doing
some songs together and I was like yeah
I'll be cool so the Vegas thing was
pretty exciting I know you talk about
dreams as well and the other parts of
the film it sounds like that's a very
strong force in your life yeah mm-hmm
and James aren't always hearing some
kind of music or I I remember a lot of
likes of like I even remember a whole
bunch of James and I was very little
then I had yeah what do you get the
sounds the smells the places the people
the environment in them mm-hmm yes what
do the two of you feel about the law of
attraction I'm wondering if that's
somehow between us well you know I mean
it was the right time if you say Rachel
that other filmmakers had approached you
and maybe either they didn't follow up
or just wasn't right and
sounds like this I don't know if you
wanted to look at a higher part of how
this song came together law of
attraction I don't know side of you so
it certainly was attracted you know in
terms of I think there's a certain
cosmic thing going on you know in the
creative realms that leads you don't
always in the right direction you know
it had a few detours as anyone else
mmm-hmm pursuing things you think are
great the world is nodding ugly I don't
think so okay but this has been three
and a half years it's a I figured it was
a four year having done these before I
think it's a four year thing for full
from conception to full release and so
we're about six months ahead of schedule
Oh in three and a half since January
18th 2014 which is the day we met sorry
something in April that year so and then
just you know I don't know we you felt
it was okay - mm-hmm
decent guy mm-hmm
you really know at first you know but
she was a great trooper you know I mean
I know it was exhausting sometimes yeah
oh it's always exciting you know I mean
I specially asked you to place on forty
time added quite good ways I probably
overdid it to a few times it's just like
which song I just played again Hey but
what I think it was you have to have to
create yourself about what the process
was like you talk a little bit it was
pretty interesting like getting all the
mics set up and the cameras and filling
strange things like going into the
pumpkin fields and it's like small thing
in this giant I don't know what it is
mm-hm
well yeah it wasn't just performance
since like I know that my other comes in
this realm has been kind of tagged music
films you know I know this was is still
going to be called that but I really
were talking make it more than that you
know family piece you know
we wanted to take Rachel into places
where blind people don't go like by
themselves in the middle of a field of
course we took her out there and then
she left in the fray but I wanted that
feeling of Independence
you know symbolic image with the drone
cameras coming back and she's good as
well yeah and it's a little unrealistic
but it's more flat sort of you can lose
them for the freedom and no boundaries
which is what I get from Rachel yeah
right but then also to structure I think
you talked about on the IndieGoGo page
and I have it here it says with a
documentary their structure and you
always need to go back to the house to
the family and I'm just wondering s
where it all starts
ok yeah we had salsa that's like where
why am i after I'm done doing something
I'm always back at the house and going
on my keyboards and composing or playing
a song or whatever these increasingly
impressive forays into the world
starting in the sequence in church where
she sings expecting it many early may
never fit in the way before nothing you
yeah that's like the it son everybody
knows the first but I like going further
and exploring your nose yeah and then we
go back to the house and it's it's it's
a conscious effort to should hopefully
it's subtle until you people do not
interfere with you will go with you
wherever you take them and if it's an
off they know when they they're not you
know and I was working for them mm-hmm
so you're not making it for them it's
it's manipulative in that sense you know
but it's mostly your abilities as an
editor when you're cutting for a year
you know it's hard to be objective
anymore
you know so you show it to people and so
on but that was a pretty early decision
was to come back and forth and then
culminating that the three jewels Apple
stuff was not at the end at one point
huh and some people wiser than I so we
just put that at the end and it was
obviously good advice yeah so you grew
with her yeah and you know when you film
that long sheet her look changes or hair
lengths that she becomes but he starts
up as a young girl into a young woman
you know that's the sort of natural
trajectory try not to get in the way of
the material you know Rachel what do you
want people to take away from the film
hmm I lost that I've watched it hmm well
they're going to they may have heard of
you some may not never occurred to you
it's hard to put yourself in their place
but you're pretty interesting for them
to see yeah how you're progressing over
the years the part about like something
about like moving forward forward mm-hmm
exploring all kinds of things and
I I know it I would like to save I can't
get the words out correctly really yeah
well she's thinking about it I'll say
that you know this also things like it's
a disability film in which it's not that
word weave is banished you know we don't
use that word if anything she's a hyper
able individual you know it's a cute
huge talent yeah but people will get
what they want out of it and some people
might that might be very productive
hearing we had the film that's been
audio described for the blind and
vision-impaired it's a narration track
so certain theaters and in fact the New
York theater has that capacity senators
and iTunes and Netflix neighborhoods of
buying the film black some some of those
types of us have that so it opens it up
for people like Rachel who need that
said watch a lot of movies right now in
a black sky of the rough sunlight cross
the earth rays of light shoot up and the
words Universal appears looks freeze now
a young man sits at a piano but it could
be any department narration is
interesting and it paints papers it's
very brief because it has to fit in
between dialogue in the movie at so your
arms down his face
bring him a tear those down his face
what advice would you have Rachel for
other people that are having a film made
about them maybe they feel like okay
this is just daily life for me
even though the rest of the world is
intrigued but what advice that you have
I mean I'm sure at times it might have
been uncomfortable but other times was
probably very exciting yeah and
flattering and then also maybe a little
scary because you're like all these
people are going to know but there's
probably a fun part of that too many
advice make sure of both do yourself
right yeah this would be like yourself
personality and
I think most people don't think see
themselves is interesting sure I mean
here in LA everybody thinks I'm sure is
a drill a different world yeah that's
impressive that there's someone who is
not motivated by that at all right I
would listen to a lot of like of
documentaries on like very famous people
who would did a lot of strange things
sort of not really being themselves at
the end and I guess and so I always like
thinking thinking of me and just like my
personality and I guess I can't figure
out exactly was the board's but like
that's real learning from from those
just being natural and also my family
too so that's pretty cool
yeah Reese's grandfather and grandmother
and with little musicians and the
grandfather died in this 2014 and made
the film even more important I think to
you guys yeah he was in it you know
daddy was he always had nice time
together too he played me a lot of stuff
with grandma like a lot of Western Swing
music when I was very little
sometimes she would be singing stuff to
me and I have these dreams were like
recently I would have these dreams was
like he he would just be singing and
just
really happy hmm
keep Emerson I Keith Emerson yeah that
was written that was the toughest for me
because I saw him two months ago before
he died he was very influential in
adapting classical music and taking that
into a rock band a keyboard based band
Emerson Lake and Palmer and earlier with
the knife back in the late 619 60s but
he was also a really really cool
composer and he would take sort of the
structure elements of classical music
and jazz and all kinds of stuff and so
that was very influential and I was
lucky to make two have met both Keith
Emerson and Greg lake they were both
very nice people and I stayed in touch
with Greg after Keith died and wrote to
him and we just had a nice time and then
he he's gone and so I was lucky to know
both Keith and Greg they helped me a lot
in finding your own path like keep
exploring things and then you finally
figure out what it is that you enjoy the
most and keep keep doing it kind of as a
Mike Anderson Lincoln Palmer they don't
make music like that as much anymore
snow it's absolutely brilliant and it ya
know much about I mean you know I'm most
of those fans are you know older guys
and showing that it kind of bypassed me
but and YouTube my YouTube videos a lot
of my youtube fans will know me as the
girl who I guess brought Keith Emerson
music back to
I guess good she's the queen of Prague
yeah I was looking at some of the
comments and people were saying I tried
in 1975 to play this and I couldn't use
I can't believe how effortless it looks
though I'm always studying the lot a
whole bunch of renditions the live
versions the studio versions different
takes or the difference yeah so it's
pretty cool let's technology now I could
listen to it listen to one part of the
song listen to it how did he play that
live okay probably change this up a
little bit here and get this there and
hmm scientist over here really you know
music is this guy's doing this trash
thing music is a science at the language
you know and she has a master's degree
in that sometimes she went to school
right yeah I went to the conservatory in
you know from the agency went away and
that was pretty good for studying
classical music a lot of times the stuff
that I enjoyed doing was just I just
like to listening to the classical music
and and going to computer class and
learning on music technology and but um
later on I started to once I started
teaching myself how to go online in high
school and how to go on the internet and
look up stuff and I started exploring
lots of cool stuff and then having some
friends too it's a mixture of my family
and then my friends and then just a lot
of stuff mhm
18 hours a day I've seen her fall asleep
playing a chord and wake up playing the
same chord
yeah it's a weird weird in a natural way
that's what I mean that somebody was
living it you know sure I thought it was
interesting too when you said earlier
Lorenzo about how being in LA and
everybody thinks their story is special
and that's true that's partly why
everybody comes to Los Angeles in some
sense but but you know I'm sure from
doing interviews and documentaries
you've probably had to ask people to
tone back you know when the camera turns
on and they get into actor mode and I
felt that very refreshing about the film
too but it was very natural and I didn't
feel that you know I'm sure you've seen
that another I've not encountered that I
mean I guess it's a choice of it you
know I really think about the thematics
you know why you make a film write a
story or something I mean in my case
like I guess it's something to do with
discovering the undiscovered you know
people that could easily be in this
frenzy of stardom be seeking the people
who get ahead usually the people who try
the hardest you know to you know whether
it's a reality TV you know unspecial or
a sex-change operation whatever it takes
you know so we'll do anything lift
themselves out of anonymity and then the
people that are famous want anonymity
back and they can't get it as it was
pushed cool thing but yeah none of the
subjects I've done whether it be tell
Farlow or this group loss of heroes from
Cuba there were none of them were show
boaters in performance they were but in
life they weren't and so Rachel's in
that family of people who are available
to they know it but they're not selling
I'm the best player in or other people
can say that if they want to but yeah
when you start saying it I'm not I'm not
like that I'm like yeah I could do that
stuff for the muscle will you listen to
a lot of other people too yeah I'm
calling daddy
yeah studying it since the scholarship
Kurt Cobain I think was quoted as saying
I remember I heard an interview from the
90s where he said he wishes that he
could just be in a band for two years
until it blows up and then jump out and
do something else because he loved a
process of building it up but the same
part like the writing part he wanted
some of the the pureness back something
like yeah I was reading about that too
that's the one I was just I'm getting
into a phase right now and exploring all
these different styles and stories music
your nerd yeah a letter any White House
songs right if you should go to her
soundcloud channel it's like
unbelievable diversity covers collection
some Frank Zappa some Prince King
Crimson Beatles like all kinds of stuff
okay cream green Clapton deep purple yes
Dre jams for George Harrison yeah yeah
actually music still plays on the radios
which is it 99 9 Kate I'd look I get
that occasionally if the Sun is right it
will come in all the way in LA but it's
in and out so I get that station at home
so I love that station I like Rachel has
a device called a victory here which is
holds the SD cards and she keeps a lot
of different cards for different lesson
categorized in genres so like one card I
put all my I guess like classic rock
collection from the stuff in the 1970s
and all that and then I put another I
would I put all this I do a copy and
paste of stuff on the computer so like
if I had like all the alternative
collection of like all those different
bands like Nirvana Pro Jam Soundgarden
another one yeah Chris Chris Cornell
yeah
magnetical voice yeah yeah spirit yeah
you'd range to vocal range yeah yeah and
they they support a lot of time
signatures Susa not just for four but
they would go into like like five and I
guess like seven and like wow this is
cool not your standard like then no yeah
but you would often associated with like
progressive rock and nuts and time
signatures that they incorporated that
into it's so cool so so I like to think
of those elements and my main favorite
in composition would be jazz and
classical but I like incorporating the
structure of classical music but also
with jazz harmonies and improvisation
the closest would be like the stuff by
Pat Metheny Lyle Mays and then a Taylor
aixi who is in the film
he's one of my influence what influences
to turn pianists and so I'm always
categorizing things so so like one is so
like my contemporary collection and then
I got one it's just my jazz instrumental
stuff and this card is more of the vocal
side of the jazz vocalists and then this
one is going to be like gospel
collection and then this is sort of like
my classical collection so and then I'm
always putting it in a specific spot so
that way I know exactly where where
where it is so it's a lot of fun having
having this technology to explore these
things and listen to them and share it
with them too so I want to make Rachel
Rachel crazy hide her security issues
where's my routine Hey was there one
moment in the film that was it was
difficult whether it was just the
location or or whatever it was that was
maybe the most trying but then it turned
out to be actually one of the better
moment
I don't remember now there was a whole
bunch of stuff that we did difficult
said no not technically did I think some
of the interviews I learned a lot early
on asking and you know in your role is
tricky because not that you see a
realist you know I think it's easier if
your music is coming from as she says a
sense of place a feeling a sound smell
who she's with
you know like compositions like at the
beach ordinary day titles shoreline the
titles indicate the genesis of this
piece is from an actual experience but
some intellectual thing so the early
interviews were to just stare at me like
what are you guys can use for you know
like where does the music come from is
it some people can answer that but it's
kind of an odd question yeah so I got
better at it you know by trying to just
steer it towards me more so I wouldn't
say those were difficult those Rachel's
was never resisting anything but I had
to learn her language and her process
took a little bit of it wasn't reminds
me of Keith Richards his son
yeah his book life actually said he
talked about uh who these people would
go to these jazz clubs and they was
theorized but they had never picked up
an instrument and he it would it would
make him mad
you know because he maybe didn't know so
much about the theory but he knew how to
play how to play guitar yeah yeah but
they have failed musician myself I think
it came at it yeah it is more terrible
point but you play sorry well what I
didn't play jazz guitar you know which
is of course the hardest type to play
shaky but the time itself our lovely
lady medics film about so I kind of
worked it out for myself
it's gave me towards film which is
better for me in it but yeah so so I you
know I music is still sort of a mystery
to me in a lot of ways but I know it
enough to edit it and work with it and
know what sounds right and what
but I you know leave it to people like
Rachel to do it you know but you have
some abilities you know as an editor to
read this stuff because you either seen
two four different people and it becomes
that differently with each person you
know terms of the sensitivity to what's
going on I like the echo in here yeah
it's very high high ceilings you had a
IndieGoGo campaign
mmm that right did most of the backers
know you or Rachel or Jimena I don't
know
mostly they knew her you know and it was
it was our first campaign we did in the
14 and we did well with it you know it
was just exploratory to see if anyone
cared you know and so when it's all said
and done there's almost you know 200
through the credits on the movie and if
you saw a version with the credits but
it's like four-minute credit sequence
which is like a big movie you know just
to thank everyone who helped out from
$10 people they all get their names on
the film and and so is astonishing RIT
like I said never never before had I had
that kind of free support and it wasn't
me I'm a few people you know but mostly
it was people who'd been following
Rachel for years said oh there's going
to be a movie about it
I'll help like that you had a fool it
was cool then we did another one a few
years later but mostly it was some in
our executive producer Patti chana and
several others who came in big you know
to support it over a long period of time
and gave me the assurance that it'll be
taken care of you know and I'm a good
negotiator so I'm not spending other
people's money unwisely but it was a
pleasure you know to know that you're
actually going to release this now
that's where
yeah because film was not that expensive
considering what other feature
documentary is not but the marketing and
when you go to the theaters and all of
this it does cost you music rights and
things showing a lot of music anything
mm-hmm
how is that to secure those rights well
it's expensive you know I mean they
don't care if it's a small film they
don't care if it's Rachel flowers it's
just you know but we have clearance
people in San Francisco who I worked
with before and they're very good you
know the rights workshop and they go
after it you know and I deal with these
publishers all the time so they say hey
give these guys a break yeah but you do
have to pay and you have to be diligent
about that I've never had any bad
experiences you know slid by on a few
titles I won't mention their names yeah
that looks not but this was anyway you
know and a lot of work you know Remora
many bucks easily but as we are in good
place now so elements I know you used to
live in Los Angeles and be in the film
industry here and then I guess you would
drive up to Ventura on the weekend for a
while that's what is it yeah so do you
miss Los Angeles do you miss the film
industry or do you do you feel that
there's a home that embraces you in
Ventura
it seems like they're bored with you
well you know this careers change times
change
I did my time in that sense you know I
did okay I did well coming from Hawaii
with no connections no experience I
wanted to be a film editor I just I saw
cabaret 14 times and it was really the
first movie it was conscious of the
craft of editing as a storytelling tool
you know and later got to meet you know
David bretherton he won an Oscar for
that film as an editor and end up
working with a couple of oscar-winning
editors
Wow in those days there was an
apprentice and a second assistant
assistant you know the older
hierarchical stage then you became an
editor you paid your dues yeah my first
summers girls just want to have fun oh
great okay go ahead fingerless gloves
yeah yeah you know and then I get fed up
with LA and I moved to Canada lived on
an island with my dog and oh wow and
then I was involved in with John Hurt
too late lovely John Hurt and a feature
called hypergraphia that I had wrote and
and he was going to star in and we spent
six years collaborating on that so that
brought me back down here isn't needed
to be a little closer to the business
but you know la will either you know
like New York you know embrace you or
ignore you you know you still have to be
yourself and so you know we've come down
a lot it's nice to be only an hour away
but I don't want to kind of leave it to
others to be here every day you know
we have a lot of new filmmakers that
watch our channel and they want to make
a living
as a filmmaker so you know you've been
in this business for a few years what
advice could you share to them about
making a living as a filmmaker is it is
it in the editing is it in
post-production or maybe production but
in terms of of actually trying to make a
movie just to make money and make a
living it's more about the idea behind
it and how passionate you are maybe not
yeah well I never did any films myself
for that reason you know to make a hit
you know
supply or genre piece you know a horror
movie or something people do that you
know and they some succeed with that I
found that seldom do they be able to
escape the thing that they started that
it could become a genre film make it so
many filmmakers knows this is amazing
every year there's people getting
graduating from film school and I think
it's harder in a way now that
distinguish yourself even though there's
digital technology and
become society in Ventura ways to bring
in some students from Brooks Institute
which is no longer there but they were
shocked to show their shorts and stuff
in front of an audience because they
usually doesn't put it on YouTube and
they go by the comments which is sort of
separate from and then that that sit in
the room in the dark with people they
were very moved by that and they had not
no experience there was a degree of
separation audience so I don't know in
terms of making a living
it's a mystery you know I had a craft
that I could sell and get paid for to do
the editing and I got on a TV series one
of ours called life goes on late 80s and
transitioned me from an editor to a
producer and directed for them to
veteran director skill and so that was
my path you know but a craft is a good
thing you know with its camera editing
and then I just always would work on the
side writing and so on you know let's
try to kind of ask at least as much of
myself as my employers asked of me which
means a long day you know you come home
from a 12-hour day and the rest when you
do your own thing with his writing or
editing or whatever you have to be
pretty resilient and I'm diligent about
it and that be like somebody else is
fine
you know who you are find out who you
are and then that hopefully translates
into something others will find
interesting to you you started the
Ventura Film Society and you said
they've taken hiatus so it's it's closed
down for a little bit but when you did
start it what were some of the issues
that other filmmakers would throw out or
not maybe not issues but just concerns
or things they were working through
people that we had up there his guest
yeah well they pretty much enjoyed you
know the process we had Paul Mazursky up
it was an old friend of mine and Bob
Young and Ondi Timoner and really lots
to do
with us they were working on their own
projects it sometimes got into that
talking with him but you know as Paul
Mazursky the late Paul Mazursky says
that he says I know I'm close to dying
because I'm getting all these tributes
now you know to get closer Oh God he was
a great guy and so that was just a you
know having been in a lot of festivals
good bad indifferent
you know festivals we wanted to honor
the process and bring to a small town we
was our slogan bringing people together
in the dark about it theater experience
and that was or discover the world
around you these are the kind of things
we came up with and and the programming
followed those leagues you know odd
things you know some went over better
than others you know so Lorenzo from
your successful IndieGoGo campaign in
2014 you said something that was great
it was making a film about someone's
life even for a short period of time
it's not something to enter into lightly
for the filmmaker or the subject it's a
bond that holds people for a very long
time before fruition and a lifetime
afterwards so remember that's
beautifully written
kind of true you know did you think rich
in terms of the relationship between the
filmmaker and a subject
mmm-hmm it's you don't quite know it's
going to go if it's going to work yeah I
lost concentration or company okay but
yeah it's true I mean if you care about
people and you know again it's this idea
of reaching into the shadows and and
illuminating stories for people you
didn't invent the story the story was
there already but you're you're kind of
the guide you know and in this case the
piece is hopefully going to resonate
with people judging by the festival
response it will you know everything's
guaranteed but they have to buy a ticket
like we did at the festival
can't like they will now coming up you
kind of get a sense that it's working
you know film is something separate from
us now it's a separate entity you know
and it goes out and does its thing and
it doesn't bore people
it's you know it's been pretty
universally liked and that's a good
thing
what's doing something right I guess you
think so yeah and bringing people
together in the dark
would you rather than make it in a
theater there's always sure yeah but you
know whatever I mean gravitas ventures
is the distributor is a digital
distributor they do see a trickles they
did we kept the theatrical for ourselves
on this when we formed the company
called 4sight releasing which is doing
the theatrical release and yeah whatever
you know I mean if people come visual
quality is different you know I think
people are watching on the bus on their
phones okay that's cool whatever not
going to take it away from them that's
whatever fits and that's what's great
about this platforms that exist now
yeah it's digital delivery and the more
people like I think Rachel was motivated
by sharing what she does mm-hmm that's
real yeah I mean I'd appreciate it
mm-hmm I love the moment where you were
I think outside the Braille Institute
and I was singing a Pharrell song
yeah which my boyfriend Eric oh yeah
that was really cool that was fine I
thought that's on costume screaming oh
I'm sure makers me yeah but it had
to be it it was excellent my favorite
dance tune so and then we cut away to
Rachel's being happy just like with the
song said it was perfect that is fine
that's interesting so you you it from
from a filmmaking sort of money
perspective that you realize that that
was a scene that needed to be there and
and yeah it got cut at one time right
before that was a superwoman keep you
under Stevie Wonder you know you don't
think about in a feature film where
you're doing a dance number lala land
isn't you've got to own that music from
early on because you're going to shoot
to it if you didn't clear it you have to
reshoot or fake it or something
the documentary is a little less
stringent but it comes to haunt you at
some point you know that's the cut oh my
god you know this we have to clear 19
songs you know I still remember the
first time I heard that song I was
actually a I was asleep when I had some
weird dream and I turned on the radio
and I was looking for a good station and
that song came I was like wow I like
this this is cool
nothing but happy yeah was it K tight or
no no no that that's that's that's
classic that's like rock but I was
probably either live 105 5 or B 95.1 or
somewhere in those it's today's hits
station you know okay right yeah but
it's you know the eric is a guy at the
Braille Institute whose vision impaired
I don't know where he is now but it
wasn't Santa fire brother yeah very
calendar you saw him with his that's
something that's an erasure him I can't
snap my fingers that thank God is one
thing but he's good great time and I
asked to and he he really cares for
Rachel so it I was just you know you
know plan these things like oh and then
you turn the camera where something's
happening here right it just comes back
you know you better be directing job to
go back to that is just don't being at
the moment I don't blow it
multiple cameras and things happen right
at the moment spontaneously yeah that
you say do it again it's never the same
yeah like okay blew it if you lost it's
your fault the energy I think having
been a photographer a story about Nancy
of the great landscape photographer with
travel to Yosemite Half Dome you know he
took some great pictures out there and
he shot you with a giant view camera
maybe an 11 by 14 negative so crisp
beautiful and he take one sheet of film
just one and drive for days and here the
processing in his trunk and then he
would take one piece of film and as a
discipline this is amazing and he could
drive all the way back print it and it
didn't work or whatever he just take one
more sheet back didn't it wasn't like
digitally just firing off because that
was an amazing story of discipline I you
know I started to use that as an
inspiration for the moment if you blow
it it's your fault yeah mm-hmm whereas
now it seems like because of digital
cameras it's just just keep clicking
just keep going yeah the world is
different to the Half Dome is not going
anywhere it's there that the rock and
the light changes the colors changed now
life is fast-moving and actual items
would be left in the dust you know if
it's a cover but that's not the kind of
guy he loves name so it's all good
whatever images that you capture or
worthy okay but there's that sort of
old-world discipline of watching waiting
yes interesting to think is any of the
filmmakers or musicians from yesteryear
would have made it and today and I know
there's the you know you talked about
home editing system and then there's
like this glut of movies out here and
the same with music as well I think they
have press pause play are probably
saying the name of the documentary wrong
but it's about home music editing system
and how now there's just so much music
out there and how to decipher good from
bad anymore and does it get watered down
as a result so yeah there's that
question with filmmaking it's great
though because it is empowering you know
the old days that power was in very few
hands
have to ask them permission to the
studios or whatever the cost have gone
way down you know until you clear the
music please
yeah you can achieve these things and
that's democratizing the process which
I'm totally in favor of and I think the
good great the good they find their own
way up to the surface you know things
that are mediocre you don't have to do
anything they'll just stay there you
know it's cool having friends to
introduce me to a lot of fun stuff you
have to share what we enjoy and if I
don't like it that's like not really
[Laughter]
embodies
for other times I feel like this is
interesting okay maybe lyrics maybe not
so much but musically what is it about
the music guys that's cool about it okay
it's got okay so it's got there's this
guy huh yeah it's a big river really you
know as all just keeps flowing going
past the first part and trying to think
of the part that makes it exciting and I
I like having my studio in my bedroom my
music studio in my bedroom I told her
once recently I said you need some
thinking of a big studio and your
bedroom be set with you but then how I
if I have a dream what will I do when I
wake up right down at the keyboard and
play the fragment I heard in the dream
yes says it's maybe let's you have a
report of a little keyboard in your room
but this way she goes right all right
Yamaha keyboard or whatever keyboard it
is and when you recorded into your
iPhone 6 yeah iPhone or Victor reader
yeah or the chords I know a lot of the
chords and the harmonies and the
instrumentation the production like on
in the dream it's like it sounds like it
came out of the album
yeah complete and you know that
transition between dreams and waking up
people had a great dream last night I
don't remember what happened you know
he's trying to capture those and before
they said mmm
it's not this world it's from another
world yeah pretty true now remember a
whole bunch of my dreams I would make a
lot of notes straight when I wake up
from that dream and I'd make a voice
note of what it was like it's a dialogue
I'm living a whole bunch of dialogue
from dreams and I even talked if when in
dreams feel like hey my voice sounds
like this because I'm dreaming you are
yeah
or I would have these dreams that I
would be singing in my voice would be
really really powerful it would be
totally different from my soft singing
voice like in the dream I would sing and
his unusual sound like how do I get that
sound in his dream and Brenda when
someone meets someone as you did with
Rachel at I want to say sour grapes
sorry squash sorry
it's quantum right teachers it's really
a smashing great I think it's a really
cool name I remember we showed the
picture and I got the really clear if
there's a lot of gazes email oh it looks
cool okay so forgive you to the club I'm
saying you're watching yes oh my gosh
grapes you know and it let's suppose we
have a moment that where they see they
meet someone incredible and they say you
know what I want to be part of that life
story I want to show the world its life
story what are like maybe five questions
that that filmmaker should ask
themselves before they embark on
something because it is a big commitment
and you are getting involved in
someone's life you know you're showing
them to the world and that's a big
commitment and you know you've done so
beautifully so what what are some
questions a filmmakers task
well it's good what I don't know if you
like Rachel that
well I mean it's time you know what
you're doing what's most important for
the moment and you know you're in for a
long experience which is done this
before or you enter it completely naive
and you learn you know it's not that we
can shoot you know it could have been
done but it wouldn't have the depth you
know what the thing we that I always
liked about this experience it was about
a little easier girl little little
person in it
Google house is this in a little town
and then she soon may say this before
but the big story you know it was
looking for the great that exists was
small with Hollywood always taking the
small and trying to make it big this is
the inversion of that you know so I
don't know I mean the question one would
ask is time how am I going to fund is
who's going to help me is this just a
momentary fascination I call it the I
did a lecture for some students at the
Brooks and I didn't I couldn't tell them
anything they didn't know about cameras
and lenses and I wrote this thing called
ten phases of addiction which is almost
like a Narconon lecture you know sure
but it for journal it video journalism
laughs like you know there's 30 people
in the room how many people are going to
be here in five years
mmm doing this kind of thing and it
won't be 30
I can guarantee you you know like really
true things will happen
you weren't really meant for that
whatever you know it's hard though it's
hard to give up and go somewhere else
but that went over well because it was
how it's almost like a junkie in a sense
here that the story is the drug you know
and if you have an in you to go all the
way for a story that you really believe
in that's essential you know to have
that clinical connection or cellular
connection with a story and that should
guide you through all kinds of ups and
downs even if you have that you have
something to go with so that would be
you know
something I would ask myself and that
others would be wise time until soon
well it's excellent do you have that
online anyone we could link to it oh
really
no kind of a lot of people focus on the
dark side I do too and this is the
lightest I think most yeah I feel good
to run a little project I've ever done
you know because it was a good time in
my life you know I was mature enough I
think the sense that the goodness that
is going on here
and that in times that are confusing
which is all the time that now
especially yeah you have an antidote
yeah to too much responsibility is on
Rachel to change the world but
successions if you feed a family
persevering through adversity with the
soundtrack going on in the house here I
think you can get a lot justifies yeah
I'm happy to have my family too so and
my brother and our kitten Jiro Wang you
know Vaughn didn't want to be in the
movie and mall I'm glad he was yeah it's
a long time with you tell him Rachel
baby girl water children Rachel Rachel
you think of his range alert you know
he's feta
yeah and Jeanne knew that I want he he
had funnier they're almost done you know
the renzo always told so he wants you in
it
no something happened she called me one
day he said Vaughn wants to be in it
okay go first
something changed he woke up he grew up
and that interview which you liked is we
like it a lot too yeah the bonus
features we gave them the little five
minute sequel okay you haven't seen that
keeping that as a surprise you touch
dirt about you guys you've heard it here
mercifully reiterates what you know here
that goes all the way and people who are
your Rachel's brother what instrument do
you play
oh yeah yeah I don't plan over it does
he has musical abilities but oh keep
keep keytar yeah here's without that for
a Christmas present
yeah but he's a terrific artist yeah
that of the fantasy realm I can have
himself a career in gaming and all kinds
of things you know bright nice graphic
novels and stuff but when the time came
to film that sequence he was he got a
haircut there's a skeleton in there is
fetal dance or something and before I
could ask him any of the questions I had
my sheep like hey he answered everything
yeah without me asking I so ask one
question says if anybody tried to bother
Rachel what would you do is I beat him
up this is my job to bother her so but
he was great and then just cut it
together and it was honest yeah and I
think the film will be less without him
yeah when you see him at the end you
know that little scene way they hug each
other at the very end
yeah is it he's not in it but she's in
the supermarket shots with a shopping he
talks about his mom it's just like there
to be more but it's at least that's
there and because he's reserved and he
doesn't really want to be part of
anybody else's scene but he loves Rachel
he loves mom
it's a great family okay that's why I
like to see night that's it it was
honest you know what whatever whatever
the feelings are around it was honest
and I feel family yeah I thought I
really went to the film yeah yeah well I
guess that's what he tried for it you
know it's just not getting in your own
way you know this is you know Michael
Moore does his thing you know he's very
much the presence in it and that works
great for him and others are more
reserved and non present you know what
we would call direct cinema you know
you're not getting in any way between
the audience and the subject by putting
yourself in you know that would be the
school that I would be part of you know
I think because it would be weird you
know I'd be like a narrator which I've
never made a film with
I've edited sums with narrator's work
for National Geographic which is very
narrator heavy Ken Burns kind of films
are very clear but they're not very
interesting cinematically they do the
job well right yes they lead you along
tell you what you they tell you what
they're gonna yeah it's much harder to
edit a film that doesn't have that
element because it has to be
self-revealing based on what what
they're saying yeah so the subjects
becomes a self narrators but we tried
not to do too many sit-down interview so
they're a few we did but we use most of
it as voiceover yeah and we go to the
picture just between quick reference
yeah so they are telling their own story
you know yeah pretty cool
yeah the grocery store and then the bus
route yeah they're like yeah currently
still talking at the nanoshells yeah
yeah Arturo Sandoval yeah I was fine he
came up with some stuff what his music
is the balm for the Soul
you know if you have music keeps your
spirit alive yeah I can't write that
stuff right and he I said what are you
gonna talk about he is I've got it
covered
everyone's trusting it playing with him
is so much fun traitor
yeah she had bet him few years before
and I hadn't met him some years before
and recalled him meet me do a reunion
sing of uhm and he said you have one
hour there's one hour we need so much in
an hour yeah the soundtrack album will
be coming out soon and there is body and
soul that they did together
yeah well which is which I forgotten
about till we pick that up and she's
right on the bosun both in jail for
piano which stewart's originally Oscar
Peterson's piano I guess yeah he owns
Oscar Peterson to nine foot boys and
girls were from Imperial he looks like a
tiny person I love the sound of huge
pianos wounded is seen of few and your
mom walking through downtown LA I think
it was that what you're interesting yeah
because it was so different from Ventura
to be just may be a safer feel more
inclusive and then just walking down the
street and I enjoyed that contract yeah
that was the day we come dat the blue
whales I love downtown with where she
plays is to trio there's a lot of
memories there in 53 days you know and
we didn't use everything we shot some
things didn't measure up visually for me
you know the location so there's nothing
like that it wasn't quite worthy you
know this is surreal
the same pose sometimes Rachel needs a
hug and she gets it mmm-hmm and I could
yeah so you can happy with energy okay
pretty good job okay yeah it's fun
nice dumb questions like I do we started
you know there's a bunch of videos
coming out over the next few weeks that
we invited to release little pieces like
Rachel playing the national anthem
you gave you that on our Facebook page
just we just released one on a pipe
organ pictures in an exhibition
classical piece and there's few more
coming so we're just kind of showing
people little pieces you know we're
going to release that night in Tunisia
pieces man Tyrion